non mais faut qu'on sorte de là on va te
rendre le studio t'inquiète va ma vie
elle est derrière et que je m'emmerde
dans un studio dans une maison de vieux
et puis c'est moi qui l'ait voulu
j'allais pas vous laisser à la rue comme
des chiens
bonjour normalement ça me rend malade
d'être savant ici occupes toi de ton cul
et commence par te faire épiler les
mollets tu as beau être blonde tu
commences à douter et moi je veux que tu
restes j'allais je vais quitter sam où
je reviens
si je pars c'est pour les gosses les
gosses oui on vole on vole tout le temps
on n'arrête pas en vols dans les
magasins sont surtout des fringues la
boue je sais pas on vole même des
allumettes
tu vois et moi comme une conne je fais
semblant de trouver ça normal c'est non
j'ai pas d'autre solution faut que je
parte je trouve pas ça peut te rendre
heureuse c'est la seule solution
mais j'en suis pas certaine du tout